hi Anita I'm Helene Gayle on president
and CEO of care an international
organization focusing on eliminating
extreme poverty we have put as a focus
of our organization improving the lives
and empowering women and girls because
we know that women and girls are both
disproportionately impacted by poverty
but also hold the solution for ending
extreme poverty because we know that
when you invest in women and girls they
are the grill change agents in their
society but we also know that they they
focus on girls can get lost and that's
why your story Anita and this panel is
so important because we know that it is
by focusing at girl on girls that you
had the best chance of changing
societies and really tapping into the
root causes of many of the problems that
we all face and are trying to solve so I
am just so happy to be able to be here
and talk about the value of the girl
effect and why we all have to do what we
can do our part wherever we are whatever
policy makers of program implementers
advocates government officials all of us
have a part to play all of us have a
role to make this girl effect when
development come alive and be able to
make what is the best investment for
saving humanity by investing other